on this episode the winners join me
let's clap it up
[Applause]
[Music]
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 125 of
the ask gary vee show it's a glorious
Friday here had some good meetings I
actually woke up in Detroit actually you
know what happened today it was the
first time in forever for all the
insanity that is my life in traveling
that I woke up 4:45 a.m. that I woke up
and wasn't sure where I was like rolled
out literally Mike I hope you're not
watching literally rolled out of bed I
was like I gotta go work out I'm gonna
go to wait I'm in Detroit I gotta fly
and then go work out so that is going on
nothing else nothing too out of the
ordinary otherwise except a packed house
let's let's get a little like here we go
let's get a little bit of a Rome on
who's in the room and then I'm going to
allow the three newbies in the room to
introduce themselves because obviously
today is the day that we that we are
announcing or displaying the winners of
the contest to come today is the special
day that is the today is the official
one so one year actually you know what a
pumped everyone's here because truth is
I think we did this once before
somewhere 60 episodes ago let's just do
it one more time and then we'll let you
three wonderful winners introduce
yourselves to the Vayner nation what
happened to go your no today still let
me should we go to Steve here those like
Gary emails that was all in the subject
line it's like guys we're gonna do a
daily you to show again let's do this
that was really a like all right it was
I remember at the beginning of the year
was like this is gonna be the year of
YouTube and then you like went off on a
bunch of other stuff we're like Oh guess
not YouTube and then all of a sudden it
was just like we're doing what I do
right yeah yeah I rock you were you were
how long in at the Sun a month in and so
what you could go to the rock and how do
we uh Andy Rock you can go to me cuz you
can like United
and and so cheer up what what hap did
you and I have we had we been like
flirting with the idea no we're gonna do
a talk show and I'm like okay you're
like okay and there was and so a year
ago today we did this everybody welcome
to the first hashtag askgaryvee I think
it's the first one but I actually do
think I tried to do this once before I
feel like I've got the team now in place
to actually do this more often
so here we go and obviously we'll do a
little clip there for a couple of
seconds I should be black and white here
alright so we did a contest for this
amazing one-year anniversary of the
askgaryvee show 125 episodes in one year
not too shabby considering weekend's
involved five days a week you know
you're talking about 250 days or
whatever it really has been 52 you know
it's you're talking about a really solid
level of commitment to the show
something I always like to talk about
people giving up I always talk about it
being a year and a half before Wine
Library TV really clicked every day it
was five days a week
this commitments been pretty good I've
been I'm oh I'm a hell of a lot busier
than I was when I started Wine Library
TV and so to get to this level I'm
pretty proud so let's get into the
introduction so why don't you tell the
vaynernation you can pass that to
somebody else on the meerkat why don't
you tell the uh why don't you tell the
Vayner nation who you are and and why
don't we give you guys each kind of like
30 seconds to do whatever you want with
it you can juggle take your shirt off to
promote you could do whatever the hell
you want
so thanks Gary Owen excuse me I'm Dallas
Hutchinson at D Hutchinson re on Twitter
you be down here nice to have people
know the show on Instagram that might be
up here
but I'm real estate entrepreneur from
Southern California and I'm just
honestly happy to be here a lot of
people have asked me you know what I do
or what my hook or what my angle was to
get on the show quite frankly I knocked
it out in ten minutes with my thumbs I
wrote from the heart and now here I am
so that's that's all I got if you want
to check out my homes it's Dallas -
Singh Kham and no thanks Gary yeah
wouldn't you wouldn't you tell me about
your journey to the show
like yesterday no really yeah you could
do that on your own [ __ ] block area
no no what wouldn't you to discover the
show how did you discover the show uh
well I was um I don't know how long I've
been following you but I've seen every
episode I've definitely been following
you probably since March is some
somewhere around there I don't remember
how I found you I just remembered from
the first thirty seconds of whatever
show I caught I said this guy is not
[ __ ] around he's not trying to sell
me anything he's not full of [ __ ] he has
an incredible amount of energy he talked
very quickly like I do I just instantly
could relate you take a spin at that
fast that quick it's awesome am glad
you're here awesome
all right now the ladies corner get out
of here Zak the Hat is amazing how are
you doing great how are you good why
don't you tell everybody who you are hey
guys my name is when we are fed from
when we offered design.com well help
small business owner eliminate tech
issues and nail it on social media
did you like I did I got a radio a very
radio Webley thank you so uh so how did
you how do you think you how did you
enter the contest what was your strategy
to thumbs through ten minutes how do you
roll actually I entered the contest I
checked my email after a long day of
work and I thought it was an interesting
question and I just finished reading
crush it and the first thing that came
to my mind was how I could relate to you
to your family as immigrants and I just
enjoy the first thing that came to my
mind I loved it and how about how about
the show how did you uh
how did you how did you find it how did
you the show following I found out about
the show when your book Jab Jab right
hook came out and I said let me find out
about this guy and the first video I was
like you know finally somebody who is
telling it like it is who's not
sugarcoating it
who's saying the truth that you need to
put some hustle out there and I was
hooked
I'm glad you made it thank you all right
my man don't worry dear oculars with the
devil that's have you've got you you
stay right there so you you say they're
all will connect the robot and we'll
hold hands okay so I'm my name is
matthew came after Matthew came on
everything so follow me there I'm mainly
a musician a singer and rapper
songwriter and I also dabble in some
video making and marketing so wearing a
few hats and yeah how I found you I read
that book right there and loved it and
then found the show a few months later
and I didn't I didn't get addicted to it
right away
I'd watch this thing a bit here and
there but I wasn't so into it my one of
my coworker my boss is actually really
into it he he turned me on to it
I think super pissed that you're here
he's not because he's not this type of
guy like he doesn't want to be he's what
he's got watches he's gonna love ya so
he's actually so honestly excited for
that because he's not the x over two
he's behind the camera yeah exactly it's
like and then and it honestly taught me
a lesson on consistency cuz you kept
doing it and then I start I was like oh
my god and then I started watching it
more and more and more until became like
a habit like it's like a daily habit now
to check if there's a new video and yeah
I went all the way back wash everything
and yeah absolutely awesome brother
glad you're here matt is a new cat
working crashed we're not having it's me
organic got it alright do rock you're
out of it today
alright well with that it's tremendous
I'm glad the vaynernation now knows you
three I'm sort of pumped for you guys is
a day that I will always remember I love
this maybe we'll do this again in
another
episodes if we're still doing the show
with that Webley this is a very exciting
part
it is probably let's get into the show
amber amber amber says if you lost
everything today what's the first thing
what would be the first no so the first
thing that you know this is a tough
question because I'm trying to give you
guys the truth in parallel with what
like would be valuable
meaning what I would do if I lost
everything you know it's an interesting
question there's two versions of it I
lost everything because I actually just
bet big let's say for example with
snapchats last round I really really
came close to betting the biggest I've
ever bet meaning if I would lose it
would have really hurt like hurt as in
like changed my lifestyle I've never
made a bet that would change my
lifestyle before and I almost considered
it I didn't it could because that's just
been my consistent theme and it was
funny I got to think about that a little
bit you know I think I spoke her maybe
this was spoke to the interns d-roc was
this with the interns when I told him
like how secretly I did want to go 2-0 I
think a way yeah so we didn't do we hid
this under show like I'm very
comfortable going back to a studio
apartment in Queens like like Rob Rocky
6 or over to hell it was where he's like
back in the same place I'm like yeah
like like everyone's like oh like I'm
like no I don't like Rocky 3 where he's
got a [ __ ] robot Butler I like
roughly 6 where he's back to zero
because I'm comfortable in that zone I'm
comfortable in all environments
I'm not comfortable because it might be
tough for my kids and my family and all
those things let's make pretend I lost
everything including my name and
reputation right because if I was to
lose something today
you know I'd still have my name and
reputation be interesting because I
would be at zero or really in this bad
place and Here I am
am I in a position to dole out advice
one of the things that I think I've I
think I've earned the ability for you
three to listen to me because unlike I
think the thing that you're all
referring to which is finally somebody's
saying yeah it's because I'm not just
entertaining it's not because I read
Napoleon Hill and decided to be like
influential on someone it's because I
actually
did something first and I just happen to
talk about how I did it and then I'm
very consistent down the line and then
you can figure out what's like that with
you and what's not like that with you
and having I try to create a line that
everyone can navigate it I don't say do
it like me I'm special I'm charismatic
I'm left right right left brain right
brain
I have disproportionate amount of hustle
in my body like I've got talent for days
I'm special and everybody else is
special in what they're good at to like
I don't know these stupid lights that
Dirac has right like I don't a duck
[ __ ] tattoo on my arm I'm not that
creative right
and so like listen what is it
it's a loon and therein lies the point
and so and so I think that I'm you know
if I started from zero with without my
reputation I would do a couple of things
one I would get a nine-to-five job so
that's a little bit of a curveball
because I need to establish some sort of
cash flow right I would literally do
that for one psychological reason
because I would have to teach Lizzie and
my kids that like like look clearly what
I've been selling and preaching I've
made a really bad turn on and I'm gonna
show you that I'm not beneath like you
know that now I think within a month I'd
probably be selling on eBay to subsidize
what that was but more importantly what
I'm trying to really figure out here as
a tangible piece of Isis if somebody's
watching right now and it's funny the
audience is getting younger and younger
I'm paying attention who's resonating
with me I think there's a lot of people
that are at a very low kind of financial
point in their careers definitely
reputation pointed in their careers low
I think the thing that I would do is I
would bet on what I'm good at which is
I'm good at selling stuff so I I do
think that I know how to make $100,000 a
year which is a load of money let's just
get it very calculated 99% of the people
watching this show probably don't make
that much money
like let's get it calibrated I know how
to make a hundred thousand dollars a
year by garage saleing fifty two
weekends a year I just do I know how to
go to Goodwill and Salvation Army and
garage saleing and then flipping things
on eBay
and so I'd probably do that first start
using some of that cash to start an econ
business using the money that I make and
garage saling to sell stuff online
something that's more scalable than the
garage sales stuff a product probably
I'd like it's so weird it's so funny
notice what I'm just doing like I just
realized in real life I'm literally
replicating what I did I was a merchant
hustler kid like and then I went and
sold the tangible product and he come
and then I would just probably replicate
my life and so and that's interesting
it's interesting that I didn't even
realize that I was saying that until
just this moment so that's what I would
do I would start by slinging some stuff
ad hoc then I would create a scalable
selling product using the best practices
and that's what I would do cool it's a
great segue yes my 12:30 just cancelled
huge lack of pressure lack of pressure
actually I didn't like that you
shouldn't told me I like what you made
of just got it okay
okay next question Charles what would
you do Wow we're I mean I'm gonna throw
a lot of people for a curveball here I
actually wish that existed I actually
think that I would be even more
successful I think I have I think I'm
doing fine financially I'm actually in
my behavior I wish my cows here and
nothing I mean I'm a conservative
way more than people think I I don't
value the dollars that much
I'm not extra we should go into James's
office right now of all the money I'm
leaving on the table at vaynermedia
because I like the feelings and all the
other things that come along in life I
actually think that if the world had no
money that I would be more successful
because I think and I've alluded to this
that my ability to communicate to people
and to story tell and to inspire and
motivate is maybe my disproportional
skill and that if I wasn't drawn to like
running businesses that I would be
absolutely in hype man
Diddy or preacher or like like you know
I I push very hard against my
motivational aspect because I don't want
to be bucketed into a motivational
speaker because I do think that it's the
cliche thing that we talked about
earlier that you to really hit on and
I'm scared that people struggle to cut
through the noise which is why I'm
impressed with the you know it's funny
you two really you two are the most
interesting for me because you're both
the parallels that happen with me right
there's only one third person it wasn't
your story would have been perfect of
the three versions of my content that's
put out instantaneous understanding
perseverance but liked it upfront but it
was perseverance and at some level thank
god you're not this but like the this
guy's full of [ __ ] and then I just
eventually got there and won that game
right so I actually think that if the
world was stripped of money that I would
be dramatically more impactful on
society and and a lot of time you know
the weirdest and only scenario that ever
goes through my mind ever of me not
buying the New York Jets ever ever is
that somewhere along the line the
chemicals inside tweak just enough to
where I become guilted by myself to give
up that part of my journey to triple
down on the other part of my journey a K
this funny story somebody sent me an
email yesterday ins said they were
disappointed at me for sending the email
and creating the contest of asking for
the books to be in the question and I
sat there with the question for like 20
minutes I said my god I will never win
this game because people are unable to
see one level deep I'm not like like I'm
not forcing people to buy that book I'm
putting out a show every single day that
is free in a world where plenty of
people monetize video content and you're
more than welcome not to participate in
that part of it and I am picking 500
other questions to put in there and it's
just interesting that there's so little
breathing room for any kind of commerce
to some people in a world where you can
provide disproportionate upfront value
and
want you to be stuck in there jab jab
jab jab world and I'm I'm wired as a jab
jab jab right hook guy if money was
taken out and the game of business was
stripped I would then have less of a
right hook mentality of Commerce my
right hook would be then to get people
to actually do it so I'd be like chasing
all of you around and me like no you got
to go do it now the motivation isn't
enough
and so I I actually think the answer to
your question in a long-winded way is
I'd be really happy and really
successful in communicating to the world
my points of view cool
let's go Webley speed it up I think it's
a mic yeah okay I think it's a waste of
my time to comment on your videos Oh
Mike let me help you tell you why you're
wrong
here we go no I think it's a really
interesting question and I think that uh
you know Mike I think it's a great
question
and I think that there's a couple of
things to figure out here one I'm gonna
assume maybe not that one of the good
reasons to think what you think and I
think a lot of other people think there
is because I'm not reading them right
like why say something if it's not being
consumed I think a lot of people
recognize I do read them because I'm
engaging quite a bit not on YouTube
which is because of the app and because
I have an awkward sign-in structure on
Google between Gary at vaynermedia and
the account we use for a lot of the
Google content I have to figure that out
so I would comment more because now it's
all mobile like I only comment Mobley so
I've got to figure that out but quite a
bit on Twitter outrageous levels on
Facebook in the last month or so more on
YouTube I will figure it out I'll use
this as a call to action but I want me
to give you a really good answer to your
question the reason you're actually
gonna start commenting it's because I
have nothing to do with the equation of
what's actually happening here let me
explain
oh that's not there I do have something
to do with it I'm the match of what's
happening with the askgaryvee show but
the truth is to really get what I want
out of it I want to build a community
cannot be built predicated on a
dictatorship or an individual it needs
to be predicated on the fact that people
are communicating with each other
what you haven't realized yet Mike is
that if you look deeply to what's going
on on Instagram and YouTube and Facebook
there is a group of 30 to 40 people that
are quietly and subtly and I would say
of those 40 people 25 are doing the
wrong version of it which they're in
they're communicating with the other
people for their own interest in mind to
siphon them into if Webley was to do
that she's in there because she wants
some of the other small business people
to take her services and that's all she
wants in a right hook right hook right
hook right hook way 25 of you I'm paying
attention are playing that game 15 of
you are not you're playing more of a Jab
Jab Jab right hook game and let's just
remind everybody Jab Jab Jab right hook
to that person that emailed and said
they were disappointed in me that is a
game that plays like this Jab Jab Jab
right hook the right hook is not you get
the sail the right hook is you've been
given the permission to have a chance to
sell so when you jab jab jab and right
hook you go for your right hook but
you're not disappointed I have not even
asked any single person here what the
update is on how many books have come in
I'm just it's just not the part it's the
permission that it created not
necessarily what the results are just
yet and so the real reason you should be
commenting on the show is because you'd
start putting out content on your two
cents in context of what was just put
out in the show format other people that
are in the trenches are actually reading
those comments plenty more of you should
be and then you start engaging with each
other and out of that serendipity much
like online library TV where there are
over 20 different wine-tasting groups
right now that have been hanging out
with each other for the last seven to
ten years drinking wine together one set
of every once a month four on every
third Wednesday for the last five years
and have built their disproportion of
best friends out of being part of a
community of a web show started by some
kid in New Jersey talking about wine
community that's being built underneath
here the way that these three you get to
interact with each other for the rest of
their lives on this connection point and
the way that you guys all have the
ability if you'd like to to create
connections of like-minded people with
very different angles and to have an
interesting situation unlike politics or
religion or other things where you have
a guy who's a paradox which then creates
fan bases in opposite directions so it's
not a complete cheap game but yet people
that can actually have empathy for other
people's points of view and collaborate
you now have the beginnings of a
community that has value to you that has
nothing to do with the person that's
putting out the content that my friend
is why you should be commenting if you
like that India you like that okay let's
take it Oh dream on dream on show this
guy's outfit as this is playing what's
up Gary Vegas draymond Green I kind of
been keeping up on your Facebook and
your Twitter and I saw where people are
struggling with identifying your passion
as opposed to calling it cockiness you
know along with passion comes confidence
and I understand that well cuz I'm the
same way when it comes to what I do I
was just wondering how do you handle
that it's something that I've dealt with
my whole life you know where most some
people don't understand that your love
for something or your passion for what
you're doing it shines through and
people have a hard time understanding
that so I wanted to know what is it that
you do to cope with that what is it that
you do to try to help people better
understand that I think that can also
help take me in the next level to the
next level in what I do and I want to
just find out how it is that you enter
that I look forward to hear back from
you thank you all right
world champ draymond Green on the show
it's the fun you must relay with you
thanks dream on I think you know first
of all thanks for watching the show
so you know and I have a feeling and
I've watched from afar how you've been
handling this as well because you've
clearly established yourself especially
with the Golden State Warriors run to a
championship this year a lot more people
are aware of you and and you definitely
come with a lot of confidence in bravado
and it's really interesting right you
your story connects with me because
you're an under sized power forward who
sometimes guards centers in the NBA and
now I just read an article the other day
that everybody in the offseason is
talking about finding their draymond
Green in the NBA that you've been
mentioned more than LeBron this
offseason about how small ball can work
and they said you've literally through
self-confidence perseverance I also know
a little bit about how your mother
raised you so I caught that part of your
narrative that's interesting to me I
think we actually connect pretty well as
a matter of fact I actually think that
you and I should play one-on-one in an
episode of the askgaryvee show just to
see if it's humanly possible for me to
score a point I think this is one of the
things that I love about about people
that think they can play NBA players on
101 I actually think that people don't
realize how pretty consistent an NBA
player against anybody who never went
past high school level basketball can
shut them out 11 nothing in a one-on-one
game so like I would be super pumped if
I could score points or dream on that
challenge is on I think you might duck
me because I think you're scared and you
know we're gonna film it but to answer
your question to answer a question in
full I think I think you just have to do
you and I think that's what you're doing
I think I talk about the truth being
undefeated
I'm a 39 year old man you're you're in
your 20s early mid 20s in early you know
20s I know that you and I and everybody
in this room and everybody watching and
listening to the show we all want we all
think about who we are from you know
social me has been really interesting to
me because I think social media has been
the first tangible expression of how
everybody wants a PR themselves to the
world even the people that poopoo it or
try to complain you know like too cool
for school or like don't believe in it
they don't understand subconsciously
every
single piece of content that every
person has ever put out on social media
has been absolutely thought through and
is and not like you're not thinking
about it it's been thought through
subconsciously it is the action and
results of the narrative that you've
been painting in your mind your whole
life of who you are who you want to be
the ambition that you want
I have outrageous disproportionate want
to be considered one of the great
businessmen of all time and want to be
known about how I did it and the way I
treated people along the way
I am very far away from that for as much
as you guys love me and as much as the
other said 99% of the world has no idea
who I am I have still not amassed the
kind of wealth that can give me the halo
effect to talk about it being a tangible
execution to that level and so I'm still
so far away but I know at 80 my actions
are gonna basically be the result of my
wants and I and I think you want to be
great and you've already at such a young
age hit the apex of your career so
you've got a different game than I do
but I think you know along with like
he's cocky or he's this or or she's
cocky and she's that comes all the
stories behind the scenes that people
don't know that I'm sure and I'm not
sure I hope that behind the scenes
you're doing these things for fans and
behind the scenes when your competitor
beats you even though you've put
everything to it there's as much as I
hate the Patriots as much as you might
hate that you got knocked out of
playoffs there's or even if you're kind
of sour about it and I get sour like if
I lose 11 nothing I won't even like
shake your hand even I'm telling you to
shake that person's hand in my advice
right now like it's it's really there
it's that respect level to the game I
think as long as you respect the game
and respect and this is something that I
think a lot of people struggle with I
respect where I'm at right now
because it's the game like I could think
maybe I'm slightly behind I could think
you know I should be a little further
along I'm just not
and it's a net-net game and so I think
that you want people to see you as self
confident not egotistical you want
people see that you're working hard that
you're not cheap in the trenches so
those actions just have to be that way
right they just have to be that way and
so for me I think you just do you and
let
chips fall where they may and and I have
a funny feeling you're okay with what
they're saying along the way as long as
you feel good about it and for me that's
my game too plenty people say things and
I just feel good about it I feel real
damn good about it cuz I'll see you I'll
see you soon
and we'll talk about it Mitali sounds
like from the old the old country where
I come hurry yes if Tom Brady asked you
a question on the part of his mess what
would you tell him you know it's funny
like I actually I actually had a very
interesting moment with myself yesterday
obviously maybe some of you saw this
picture and a lot of people then put out
like did Gary Vee pay the plane to fly
over Boston and say look up cheaters and
it was funny I was sitting there and I'm
very very in 2000 I'm gonna tell you
guys a story in 2008 in the midst of
Wine Library TV exploding somebody it
was the first time that I was starting
to get attention at any kind of level
outside of a small circle and it was I
don't know if it was an article or a
conversation I don't remember but I read
something about the notion of was that
this person or or this story I read was
talking about becoming a caricature of
yourself and it really hit me and I
would say to myself huh am i forcing the
narrative on like am i becoming more
hyperbolized more energetic more intense
to pander to what the audience is giving
me am i becoming a caricature of myself
and I don't know if I've ever really
answered it right like it's really it's
it was very difficult for somebody
that's really in tune I was really
struggling to unpeel the banana and be
like am i am i and and it's interesting
I'm starting to you know like if that
really had like what if it really
happened right we just had a famous
athlete asking a question one second go
like what if Tom Brady hit me up and
asked me like would I be like Oh Tom I
wish your I wish your leg fell
your body there's just no I'm just I'm
not that human right and the truth is
it's actually very hard for me to be
upset with an athlete even though that's
where I get sports muscles ache a you
guys know what beer muscles are right
somebody gets drunk and they want to
fight I get sports muscles I'm at a
sporting event I want to fight but
outside of it especially right now in
non football season I feel like I'm
almost becoming a character of myself
outside the football environment of
hating the Patriots and and it was
really interesting I literally thought
about that yesterday and so being honest
with myself if he hit me up and asked me
a question I'd probably give him the
best sound advice that I could and I try
because there's still a good part as I
was just about to say that there was a
there's a part of me like this is the
moment where I can finally put the nail
in the coffin and sabotage him I mean
the truth is he's getting close to the
end of his career it's funny Coby hated
him my whole life like just hated him
sorry but now kind of brute for him
because he's an underdog I love
underdogs right and I think tom is the
complete and utter reverse of that in
our society today and in my division so
it makes me very easy to dislike him
look he destroyed his phone
systematically to conceal the evidence
nobody in public domain no matter what
he does is going to believe him so many
people over and over talk about the fact
that people don't care that much about
the crime they care about the cover-up
like it's unbelievable what America does
with the cover-up versus the actual
crime literally probably right up to
where it gets to the ultimate like a
murder I don't think we're like all
right but like underneath that I mean
there's like I think we can all I don't
need to say now there's four to five
things in society that can be done where
the the the issue is the issue but boy
all those thousands of other things
there are actually things we're more
than willing to let go away because we
have all have empathy to know that we're
not perfect and we all have our
skeletons in our closets it's when you
try to trick us after we the collective
United States the collective world have
put you on such a pedestal and you've
been rewarded with the riches that come
along with that and so I would say to
him to have empathy and and to
understand why it's happening
and and and I would probably tell him
which sucks but this what I tell him I'd
probably tell him look the truth is the
more you fight this the worst you know
the more you approach it with empathy it
is what it is the chips have fallen and
you know you're probably too emotional
passionate to apologize or admit I don't
think you have to do that I think you
just have to go neutral for a long
enough period of time and I don't think
anybody cares 24 months from now other
than passionate patriot and anti piece
rate bands that debate this for the rest
of your career at a font
you know fondness of debating around
sports that's probably what I would tell
them fit that's it alright so with that
I hope everybody has a tremendous
weekend thought that was a really good
show I mean clearly cuz it's the I need
it I'm gonna need a graphic here for
this Zack because it's the golden does
you know what you just happen to have
the right spot to do this I'm gonna
allow you to ask the question of the day
and so you don't have as much time as
you think right my question today is
this what motivates you to do what you
do let's come on very solid way to know
the audience thanks for being on the
show thank you thanks for recording the
show thank you
thanks for asking questions on the show
thank you you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
that guy take a over light job not cool
I'm on top of the ocean living like life
in frozen feeling my feet been chosen
for something
oh sure mama told me imma be somebody I
ain't never gonna be nobody no no I
never gonna need nobody no cliff anger
yes I so do banger I'm the new Mick
Jagger I'm the new Mick Jagger didn't do
it for the girls do it for the money
didn't do it for the fame now I do now I
do now I do